the jurogan experience they found some
of those teeth and uh shipments of
dragon bones
oh what the [ __ ] were dragons what
is that i'm sure they were selling them
as dragon bones yeah but like
i wonder what those were probably rocks
or something
they collected 47 teeth among shipments
of end quotes dragon bones
speaking of dragon bones anybody like
heard from charlie sheen lately
remember that guy that's like yeah tiger
bud
dragon bones my friend saw him at a
restaurant one time look at the [ __ ] out
of here and he takes a video he goes
look he eats
because he's just the guy's going like
this like just imagine that
that that guy had achieved like this
enormous
oh here goes from baller to squalor
charlie
sheen moves into modest malibu apartment
after he's forced to live with his dad
80 and mom 76.
oh it is man i heard he lost all his
teeth i heard something oh he's i know
he's unwell so i guess
well that's what becomes see if you can
find the most current
photo of charlie sheen i figured that
would have had it didn't i remember when
like people were using hashtag tiger
blood and that wasn't that long ago
right it was like 15 years ago
no not that long yeah
and he went off the rails that was a
crazy time well when people found out
that he had hiv that's when they were
like
not so funny anymore and you know he
possibly had given it to other people
not the coolest thing charlie he was the
guy that was like you remember when he
did that interview
where he was like yeah i [ __ ] smoke
crack
yeah i love it i would uh tiger bliss
smoke grams of it yeah
hashtag winning did he even use hashtag
winning or did you say winning
he used hashtag winning i don't think he
does anymore i mean but
he i don't think he said hashtag winning
i think he just said winning
yeah winning and he was he was uh he was
smoking
half a year ago jesus christ please play
that play that this is going
to get some volume he's doing for cameo
it's a thing
is it not working i won't remain here i
will i will remain available
if if if you can all agree that uh
that that all the tiger blood and
winning and
if we could just kind of just
kind of leave that where it belongs in
the past
um oh yeah this is tough to watch man
it's a very difficult it sounds like he
doesn't listen keep going
that that that we're all finding our way
through so
so if a message from me can can can
brighten the day of yourself or
or a loved one or even someone you don't
really care about
then uh then i'm then i'm honored to
to offer that so uh greetings
good people of planet cameo it's the
sheen
i'm back whoa that's heavy
i remember when he was doing live
performances or he's going out and he's
doing he was selling out theaters
and the first one he did was a like
everybody was excited to see him
but then they realized this is after he
got fired from two and a half men they
realized he
really didn't have an act yet so then
he realized like i gotta do something i
sold out all these theaters and
now people are going to scream at me and
be mad at me because he was like [ __ ]
in trouble you paid to see me you
[ __ ] losers like that kind of [ __ ] he
was just being defensive right right
then he hired my friend russell peters
and russell peters
took over and was like interviewing him
and then the shows became actually a
success
because russell is very entertaining and
what do you what are you doing
canada representative hold on he says
that this isn't new but uh
he blames all of those fun quotes on uh
too much testosterone cream he was using
to try to get his libido up
roid ridge accidental roid rage that's
what tiger blood came from
nothing to do with coke you know who the
by the way do you know who the last
noted celebrity was to visit to visit
marineland who russell peters
oh let lo scroll up let me see what he
looked like back then
no no i'm sorry scroll down the video
like look how good he looked he looked
vibrant
it is sad to see where he's gone in his
voice there's just nothing let me hear
that
that's michael strahan is interviewing
us good morning america i am for eight
months now i've been enrolled in an fda
study
for a medication for a drug called pro
140 that's that's in
in the late stages of its of its of its
trial run we are
very close to being approved um and it
is not this
hideous cocktail that leads to so many
side effects emotionally and physically
it's one shot a week it's going well and
i i feel like i'm carrying the torch for
a lot of folks out there that are
suffering
from the same same thing you know and
all of this that has happened
have there been a silver lining oh yeah
yeah yeah i know i mean the day i got
the day i was diagnosed
i immediately wanted to eat a bullet can
i stop at that positive
star wouldn't michael strahan is such a
stud that his lisp
actually helps him become more endearing
we never fix the gap in his teeth yeah
but it's also like it's like such a
[ __ ] alpha such a a beast of a man
such a manly man he invites you to
criticize it but he when he has a little
list be like
i like you a little bit more it's a
little bit a little bit easier
to deal with the fact that you're uh a
superhuman
but i think that he was talking about
hiv yeah this one he was yeah
i want to go way back see this was what
year was this
three years ago jesus jesus christ he
looked so much better three years ago
what is going on man that's a it's a
really sad thing to see because you know
he he was
i mean he captivated the world for a
while i get it but it's so sad to see
you know there's something about someone
who becomes uh humble later and i mean
there's a level of humility that
is evident in that video where we watch
that he's he's trying to
get some cameo orders like it was a dude
that was also
he was embracing being like uh shamed
he was like yeah i smoke crack yeah i
i like i pay hookers to leave like he
was
he had all this wildness to like the way
he was accepting
this [ __ ] like a defiance people were
like yeah because people were tired of
people being
like they're being humbled by this and
goes back to the genuine and the honesty
factor i mean is there anything more
honesty than admitting your uh
drug addiction it was a little bit it
was that but it was also that he used to
be
charlie sheen he was charlie sheen from
major league and
platoon and he was a massive movie star
and then all sudden here he is on
television talking about smoking crack
he had tiger blood
he was a giant uh conspiracy theorist
for a while too
remember he wrote a letter to obama uh
demanding that obama release the truth
about 9 11.
do you remember that jamie no i was just
about to ask you where
what i couldn't remember where this all
started
the charlie sheen stuff you know like
where where did that first
hit was he live streaming on something
or well he got fired
from uh it was the firing that's yeah
that's what propelled him he got fired
from
two and a half men and then he went off
on he started calling the
the guy by his uh his proper jewish name
so it started off as
he started and then he went off who do
you call oh the chuck law
alex jones man speak it out alex jones
uh called me once he goes hey joe
someone wants to talk to you
and he puts me on the phone with um gary
busey
oh [ __ ] post motorcycle accident and
gary busey was i mean it was literally
like i was the the beneficiary of uh
this long rant i go hey man what's up
and i was like hey joe i want to talk to
you about the universe and life and
expanding consciousness and all these
different things that are happening to
you right now and this is all
and gary busey like just talked
at me for a few minutes and then gave
the phone back to alex
and i go what the [ __ ] was that i'll
call you later man
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience